let's do this
this is the closest decision i have ever
had to make ever
[Music]
the sicka sword
the sikka is a short but dangerous sword
widely used by gladiators in ancient
rome since it was customary to fight
with armor the blade featured a sharp
curve specifically designed to get
around an opponent's shield a gruesome
killer warriors would use its lethal
inner edge to sever limbs or the blade's
deadly point to hook into the jaw and
pierce through the head today the sick
is often depicted in popular culture
during graphic gladiator battles most
notably in the television series
spartacus blood and sand
bladesmiths this is the kill test
i'll take your zika sword and deliver
killing blows on this ballistics dummy
frank you're up first you ready hell
yeah let's do this
nice
well frank your blade is sharp
in combat the sikka is sometimes using
its curve to pull away the sword and
come in in this case he pulled away the
head
overall your weapon
will kill thank you
tony you ready
let's have some fun
all right tony this is a scary sicka
sword on the initial hack into the chest
cavity it penetrated so deep
it totally demolished this ballistics
dummy overall sir your weapon
will kill
tony's blade just performs great on this
thing i mean even though they both will
kill it's just looked a little bit more
violent so it has me a little a little
nervous
gentlemen this is the strength test in
order to test the strength and
durability of your blades i'm going to
attack these shields remember this test
is all about what the shields do to your
weapons and not what your weapons do to
the shields frank you're up first are
you ready yep let's do this
[Music]
well frank
your edge held up perfectly all right
it's still straight it's still sharp
everything is still tight and solid
well done thank you
tony you're up next are you ready yes
well tony
your edge held up perfectly as well
razor sharp i see no problem with the
edge from the shield
you know a nice solid blade well done
thank you
good job
all right gentlemen
now it's the sharpness test i'll be
cutting through this sugar cane one cut
with the front edge of your blade one
cut with the back edge all right frank
you're up first you ready oh yes
[Music]
all right frank right off your blade's
got a really nice balance to it
you can see on that first cut it kind of
pulled in my hand but
it's still a good feel on the back cut
blew right through any gladiator using
this be quick be deadly well done thank
you all right tony you're up you ready
for this yep
[Music]
so tony
is it sharp yes it's very sharp and it
cut very nicely it's still right still
tight
hold on
bladesmiths over the course of three
rounds both of you has displayed
excellent bladesmithing talent however
in this arena of competition there can
only be one champion
tony
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion
frank unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut
frank first up i want to say that there
are no losers in this round but we can
only pick one winner both weapons were
very sharp both weapons are very strong
but the sikko was a gladiator's weapon
and your weapon was outperformed in the
kill test as for that reason we're
sending you home all
totally understand frank please
surrender your blade
i'm fine with this result they both
killed but
his uh really killed
tony's already invited me to come up
there and forage he's going to show me
some stuff
i'll know tony probably the rest of my
life
tony congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job how do you feel right now
i feel pretty good all right well tony
please present your weapon to the judges
just
okay i'm still here it's not a dream
i won it's awesome
how do you put it in words
game i saw in the concord
a pair
of gnunting swords
as one of the weapons issued to the
philippine military special forces units
the gnununting swords have proven to be
effective and deadly weapons the word
gennunting translates to scissors and
the inward curve of the blade's design
allows for deeper cuts while also
proving the user with a thin lightweight
weapon when paired together as a sword
and dagger the longer sword serves as
offensive long-range weapon while the
shortest sword serves to be defensive
post-war weapon the intimidating dual
swords are built for brutal combat as
well as navigating thick jungle terrain
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
keel test
to find out how lethal your weapons are
i'm going to take your weapons and
deliver some slashes and thrust in this
big carcass brian you're up first you
ready for this
tear it up you mad dog i will
[Music]
nice
all right brian's talk about your
genuine things here first off for
genuine things they're a little bit on
the heavier side but that lends itself
to cut deep into the big carcass your
handle construction is smooth and it
gives me good retention and overall sir
you're getting things
you have will kill
nice
all right chris your turn so you ready
for this
absolutely all right let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
all right chris let's talk about your
goon things here
first up what i like about your weapon
here is the balance it's nicely
distributed
the edges you have here
are sharp as you can see
pretty much cut a lot of this pig up
overall sir you're getting things
you'll kill awesome
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
the bamboo chop
to test the strength and durability of
your blades i'll be taking your nunching
and chopping into our bamboo target here
with now remember this isn't about what
you're gonna done things do to that
target but what that target can do to
your gnunting brian you're up first you
ready yeah go ahead ain't got nothing
else to do this afternoon
all right brian first off
they've got some heft to them but they
don't feel bad they actually swing
pretty good your blade picked up
just the teeniest roll and then on the
smaller the two blades there's a again
it's just the smallest deflection other
than that they held up beautifully well
done thank you very much
chris you ready to play
sure
all right chris right off
your handle design for me is just about
perfect as far as swinging these things
man they're super light the balance is
really nice on these
i don't feel anything on your edge when
i run my fingernail up this thing
no deflections no rolls so good job
thank you
all right bladesmiths we know your
blades can kill and we know they're
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp your blades are this is the
sharpness test the animal hides slice
now to find out how sharp your weapons
are i'm going to take your genuine
things and i'm going to thrust and slash
across this animal hide brian you're
first you ready for this
absolutely all right let's do this
[Music]
all right brian the edges you have here
are sharp
every cut over there is quite clean
no jagged edges and overall sir your
weapon you look up
thank you sir chris your turn so you
ready yep all right let's do this
all right chris first up the grinds that
you have here are perfect for this kind
of cut because there is no resistance
overall sir you're getting things
it'll cut
thank you
well gentlemen we had three tests
we got two smiths
but we can only have one winner you guys
both performed very well but as you know
only one of you can go home the title of
fortune fire champion and a check for
ten thousand dollars the judges have
made the decision
and today's fortune fire champion is
chris congratulations
brian unfortunately your blade just
didn't make the cut dave baker's going
to tell you why
brian i think i can speak for all of us
when i say that competitions like this
are the ones we love to see where smiths
bring back weapons that are so closely
matched this came down to the smallest
things chris's blade was a little bit
sharper than yours it didn't take any
damage you did a great job it's a
beautiful blade
thank you
well brian you're clearly a very
talented smith and your work speaks for
herself on that but unfortunately your
time has ended i'm gonna have to ask you
to please step off the forge floor
i put forth my best effort but it is
what it is
chris congratulations you are today's
forged and fire champion you got
yourself a check for ten thousand
dollars
my blades performed very well i thought
it would be awesome for my kids just to
prove to them that if you put yourself
out there and put the work in you can
accomplish what you're after my name is
chris o'brien and i am the forged and
fire champion
the skiavona
rising to popularity in italy during the
16th and 17th centuries the ski of ona
became the trusted weapon for
mercenaries recruited to guard the
venetian head of state the sword's long
blade included multiple fullers to
lighten its weight while its straight
double edge made it conducive for deadly
thrusts and cuts the most eye-catching
feature of this blade was its basket
hilt with multiple pieces of steel that
intertwined to protect the hand from
brutal slashes its attractive yet deadly
qualities are why the ski of ona can
still be found today in popular games
such as assassin's creed all right blitz
bits as you can see i'm still recovering
from an injury
so to be my arm today and to have the
pleasure of testing your weapon i'd like
to bring back one of my favorite
students
my brother rj markita
all right brad the one issue i have
about your handle right here it did
cause some issues by rubbing against the
thumb right there
but more importantly it is a sharp plate
for slashing and thrusting it will
kill cool
jeff you ready let's do this
[Music]
all right jeff a little bit on the
inside of your basket hilt right there
it did dig in into his knuckles
but overall if we're talking about a
killing blade here with good balance and
the kind of destruction it did
it will kill
good job all right bladesmiths next stop
is the strength test
ben
to test your shibonas basket and blade
i'm going to punch into these terracotta
pots and then chop into these birch logs
and remember it's not what happens to
the valves or the wood it's what happens
to your blade
brad you're up first you ready
mashiavona is definitely ready
well brad once i started chopping into
that log it was just going the whole
time
there is a tiny little deformation right
there
it's pretty narrow
you can hear it you know
all in all it's sharp and it's a good
chopper nicely done thank you
all right jeff you're up you ready let's
do this
nice
well jeff
this is a heck of a chopper it's got a
lot of forward weight it's a little bit
on the heavy side but not too much
in general and in total it held up very
well nice job thank you
all right gentlemen this is our
sharpness test a rope and sandbag slash
what i'll do to test the edges of your
blade is slice the rope releasing the
sandbag then cut the bag what we want to
see are good clean cuts through the rope
and clean cuts through the bag brad
you're up first you ready ready
okay brett on the cuts
pass through the rope with no problem
this blade has a beautiful edge
a fine cutter excellent well done thank
you
jeff you ready let's get it on all right
let's do this
i think right now we're almost dead even
couldn't be any closer
all right jeff what i like about your
blade is it's look this industrial look
it's cool
it didn't slice all the way through the
bag but it cuts very cleanly
nicely done
thank you
brad jeff
you are both extraordinary weaponsmiths
but there can only be one force to fight
your champion
jeff congratulations
you are our newest forged and fire
champion brad unfortunately your weapon
did not make the cut fred this is
probably the most difficult hilt design
we have sent any of our smith's home to
do and you both did a really nice job
and we had to look at the finest of
details and that that rolled edge you
took in the strength test
and that's why we've got to send you
home
brad please surrender your weapon
i did the best that i could and i put
every single bit of effort into my blade
and jeff i hope we become friends
forever
i definitely have a lot to learn from
you
and i'm just so close to being the
champion
jeff you are the new forged and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
my heart's pounding out of my chest this
is what i came here to do please present
your weapon to the judges i feel
freaking awesome
this is everything this is what i want
he's perfect
i heard brendan might have called me
magic mike but i tell you what the magic
is floating baby magic is floating
the sword of saladin
this 12th century sword belonged to
saladin a powerful muslim leader and the
first sultan of egypt in syria believed
to be forged from steel far superior
than any other weapon of the time the
sword is rumored to be the sharpest in
history featuring a thin edge geometry
the lightweight curved blade is designed
to effortlessly deliver deep cuts and
lethal chops with the help of this
deadly weapon saladin founded a dynasty
that ruled much of the middle east for
the 12th and 13th centuries the sword is
a prominent feature of a statue
memorializing saladin that stands in
front of the ancient city of damascus in
syria
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapons will do i will take your version
of salatin's sword and deliver some
lethal blows on this ram carcass brian
you're up first you ready for this no
but i guess you got to do what you got
to do absolutely let's do it
all right brian's talking about your
version of saladin's sword here i
noticed you have something inscribed in
there what is that that is saladin in
arabic very cool very cool now your edge
you have a sharp edge
this is a very tough ram carcass on the
neck chops it cut deeply and of course
on the body it cut through in three
slices
overall sir your weapon
will kill thank you sir
all right walter your turns are you
ready let's make some ram chops
exactly this
means all right walter first up your
edge
this is a wicked sharp grind
actually when you know it sings to me
when i just touch it and pull it out
it is sharp cutting through hair a thick
spine and into the meat
overall sir your weapon
will kill thank you sir
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for the strength test
now saladin's army in the 12th century
would have faced off against men wearing
chain mail carrying shields and probably
a helmet now to test your blades
construction overall durability i'll be
hacking into our armored warriors here
brian you're up
go ahead i am
rather nervous i'm not sure what's gonna
happen
wow
all right brian blades this sharp and
with this kind of edge geometry often
take a fairly substantial rolling when
they go up against armor
yours really didn't i mean there's a
three
spots i can feel if i run my fingernail
along it just beautiful job well done
thank you sir all right walter you're up
let's do it okay
oh
nice
all right walter
there's
a little bit of a glinting and a little
bit of a rough spot here here
and maybe here other than that this
blade still has a wicked edge on it
curvature's really really nice you
nailed it scale right on well done thank
you sir you bet
close race
all right bleed bladesmiths welcome to
the sharpness test to find out how sharp
your weapons are i will take your weapon
and i will cut through these egyptian
rugs now i'm looking for clean cuts
brian you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
all right brian let's talk about your
blade here
it is razor sharp as i punctured and cut
through the carpet there were very clean
cuts overall sir your edge
it will cut thank you
all right walter you ready absolutely
let's do this
so that ring
all right walters talk about your weapon
here
razor sharp it was easy to penetrate
very easy to drag across
these are very clean cuts overall sir
your weapon
you will cut thank you sir
well guys you both brought us immaculate
weapons that performed almost
identically but the judges do need to
make a decision and choose which of you
will be crowned forge and fire champion
while they deliberate i'm gonna have to
ask you to step off the fourth floor
it's nerve-racking being up against
somebody who's as good as walter i don't
know what's gonna happen
well guys what do you think what i saw
that's about as close as it gets these
are two weapons that are so closely
matched um
they're both beautifully made i think
they test it out
virtually identically yeah
one blade stood out just a little bit
when i was doing the sharpness test
because it sang to me
hearing it ripped through the carpet and
that quintessential
okay so you guys are on the same page
then
i think so all right i knew brian was
going to be stiff competition
and he absolutely brought it and i feel
like i brought it too
all right gentlemen
the judges have made the decision
today's champion is
walter
what what
i'm just a jock
i can't believe this now unfortunately
brian that means you did not win today
this is the closest decision i have ever
had to make ever
brian
you brought us an absolutely beautiful
weapon it tested fantastically it felt
fantastic in my hand we made this
decision based on the smallest of
details and it came down to the
curvature of the blade yours just has a
little wobble in it the other doesn't
it's that close you should be incredibly
proud of that blade and it was an
absolute pleasure to be able to wield it
thank you very much
brian unfortunately that means you
didn't make the cut today i'm gonna have
to ask you to head off to force four
bro it's been an honor i'm a little
disappointed to not be in the winner's
circle but very proud of the fact that
dave said it was one of the hardest
decisions they've ever had to make feel
i did pretty good
well walter congratulations buddy you
are the fortune fire champ and you'll be
going out of here with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel i don't
even know right now
i won
i can't believe it
10 grand is nothing to sneeze at but i
want to take a portion of it and donate
to some kind of cancer organization
cancer's taking a lot of people away
from me that i care about took my dad
and i want to be able to give back a
little bit
what a wild ride
[Music]
[Music]
the copy line
according to legend the compilant was
the sword that killed explorer ferdinand
magellan at the battle of maktan in what
is now the philippines
the heavy spur tipped sword was used by
island warriors in battle and could chop
off two heads in one swing
the single edge blade could also cut
through its scabbard with no resistance
allowing it to be quickly wielded
without being unsheathed
the campylon's distinctively carved
wooden hilt was sometimes embellished
with strands of hair
offering a unique and appealing
appearance for this otherwise deadly
weapon
all right gentlemen to test the
sharpness of your blades i'll be
chopping through our cat's cradle of
rope here now todd you're up first you
ready in order to help me
[Music]
all right todd this blade
has all the weight right here you know
it's a weapon that's designed to be used
one or two-handed but controlling all
that forward weight definitely puts this
as a two-hand only sword
it's a good-looking piece and it
definitely is a cutter
michael you're up you're ready let's do
it
still a very heavy weapon
i would have zero confidence swinging
this one-handed they wouldn't get away
from me but the weight distribution on
your blade is further back which gave me
quite a bit more control
to chop those ropes
it's definitely a cutter so
good job nicely done thank you
bladesmiths this is the kill test i'm
going to take your campilon and deliver
lethal blows on this big carcass
todd you're up first you ready i sure am
[Music]
all right todd the swing over here
almost cut all the way and of course
with an easy swing on the way back
it cut the pick in half
the campilon
will kill
thank you all right michael your turn
you ready let's do it let's do this
i'm excited
i want to see my sword cut through a pig
all right my so even though it is a
heavier blade its counter balance allows
to wield going forward
and backward easily so it was an easy
recovery for the final chop
overall your compiling will kill
thank you good job
all right gentlemen to test the strength
and durability of your blade i'll be
chopping into this green bamboo i am
praying that my edge holds up
[Applause]
yeah i don't feel any damage whatsoever
on the edge
it did a job on that bamboo and it's
clean
well done
thank you michael you ready let's do it
okay
well
i thought i saw something but it was
just bamboo stuck to your blade
it's fine there's no damage there
your blade hasn't changed shape at all
good job well done
going in like this and we're so close
now it's up to the judges it's their
pick
and so i'm a little nervous
all right blade smiths from the moment
you guys lit those cold forges until
this moment you've put in a lot of hard
work it's been a lot of stress
but in this arena of competition there
can only be one forged and fired
champion and that champion is
michael congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion
todd unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
todd this is what we judges expect in
the third round two beautiful blades
equally matched but it comes down to the
finer details
your blade isn't as well balanced as
that of your opponents and your design
and detail were not as strong
so for those reasons
you have to let you go
understand
be proud of your work todd because it
was a close call
but please surrender your weapon
i never thought about making it this far
this is the first sword i've ever made
i'm proud of what i did michael
congratulations you are the forge of
fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
brother
[Applause]
all right what's going on inside of
there it's surreal uh
wasn't expected starting this
competition but huge affirmation of my
skills please present your weapon to the
judges
it's surreal it hasn't really set in yet
all the years that i've put into this
hobby this craft and now to be here and
be the fortune fire champion it's pretty
amazing
the shamsheer
descending from the saber family of
sorts the shamsheer which means curved
like the tiger's tail first gained
popularity in persia and quickly spread
throughout the former ottoman empire
light and weight and easy to wield this
deeply curved sword featured a thin
blade and a tapered tip that was most
effective when delivering sweeping or
hooking strokes it was sharp enough to
slice adversaries in two
although use of the sword declined in
the 20th century it was rebirthed as one
of the main weapons the protagonist and
film prince of persia the sands of time
to test the sharpness of your weapon
i'll be cutting through these three fish
andrew you're up first you ready for
this there goes nothing
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so first thing it's not a
light sword but the weight's where i
want it to be
beautiful looking handle
having said that up here at the front
it's a little blocky
but it's definitely sharp
well done thank you
all right tim you ready for this i'm
ready
this blade is
wonderfully fast and light
your handle i like the construction of
it what i have a problem with is this
transition the two materials it creates
a bit of a lip if that wrap went all the
way down i think it would feel
pretty good
having said that this is a beautiful
piece and it is definitely a cutter
thank you
next up is the kill test and for that
i'll give you doug
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take your sham
shearer and deliver slashes and a thrust
on these big carcasses andrew you're
first you ready let's do it
andrew
your shamsheer just became a sham wow
your blade on the initial thrust
penetrated easily and it lacerated
cleanly into the carcass
your weapon sir
will kill
good job thank you tim it's your turn
shall we have fun
let's do it let's do
this all right tim
this is what a sham sheer i believe
should feel like
it definitely
can thrust into the carcass it hit bone
i felt it i could feel it crunch
the edge here is sharp enough to
lacerate through the carcass cutting all
the way through
overall
your weapon will kill
thank you
next up is a strength test dave
now the shamsher was a weapon that was
used both on foot and on horseback so to
test the strength and durability of your
blades i'm going to chop into these
horse skulls three times
andrew are you ready for this
i guess okay
[Applause]
[Music]
so right off i can feel a slight rolled
section where the edges just deformed a
bit
but uh other than that
held up beautifully
well done thank you
[Laughter]
good smile tiff it's your turn
let's go
[Applause]
okay i can see
where your edge
is taking some deformation here
it's light and it's fast
but
it looks to me as though
your blades picked up a slight roll that
way that i did not
see before
your blade goes off at a bit of an angle
blade smith's a final decision has been
made
only one of you can be the forced and
fire champion
and that champion is
andrew congratulations you are the
forged and fire champion and will be
receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars yes
tim unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut
tim this is the kind of third round
weapon we love to see something we can
really put to the test now both your
weapons had handle issues both your
weapons rolled an edge
yours picked up a bend in that final
strength test and that's why we're
letting you go home but that was a
pleasure to use and it's a weapon you
should be proud of thank you i am
tim please surrender your weapon
i enjoyed the competition immensely it's
been one of the highlights of my life
andrew congratulations you are the
forged fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars yes
i definitely feel relieved it feels
great i mean i came here to win and
prove to myself that i was able to do it
and i can hang with these other guys
with their credentials and whatnot i
don't have any of that i'm just a guy
from the woods you know
the maguro bocho
also known as the tuna sword the maguro
bocho is a specialized cutting tool
designed to fillet massive bluefin tuna
this impressive blade is not your
average kitchen cutlery with a total
length up to three feet long these
culinary swords are often hand forged by
the same sword smiths that make the
iconic japanese katana they feature a
thick spine and razor sharp edge that
cuts effortlessly through any large fish
the maguro bocho is still used today by
some japanese chefs and can be seen on
full display at some of tokyo's iconic
fish markets
all right bladesmiths to find out what
kind of lethal damage your maguro bochus
will do i'll take your weapon and make
some lethal cuts on these six different
fishes
just you know first you ready for this
let's make some sushi
way to go man thanks
all right justin let's talk about your
weapon here first up your edge
one and done for all the cuts here it's
a very sharp edge
i like the handle construction here it's
all void so my hand matches nicely and
wraps around it
overall sir
it will kill thank you
all right doug you're up next you ready
have at it
all right all right doug first up the
handle construction
i really like the way you shaped your
handle here because typical japanese
style
now
it's a lighter blade but your edge
is so sharp it cut cleanly through the
fishes easily
overall sir
it will heal
thanks
all right gentlemen i think you know
what time it is it's time for the
strength test now we're calling this our
bose staff attack
[Music]
now justin your weapon is already locked
in our device here and i will be
attacking it with our waxwood bow staffs
this test is not about what your blades
do to that staff what that staff's going
to do to your blade all right all ready
let's do it okay
oh
[Music]
all right justin um you know this is a
brutal test for what is technically a
large kitchen knife
but uh you did very very well
right where my finger is there's the
smallest of chips and it's when i say
smallest of chips i mean it's really
small
everything else looks right and tight
all in all you did a great job you
survived thank you you bet
all right doug you're up you ready as
ready as i can be okay cause this is fun
for me
so dug right off
this is a remarkably light
there is the slightest rough spot but
besides that i don't see any deformation
in your blade
blade's as straight as it was when we
started out
it's a good solid piece hold on thank
you
so all right gentlemen two tests down
one test to go
all right bladesmiths
we're cutting it close we know that both
your weapons can kill and we know
they're strong
now it's time to find out how sharp they
are
this is the sharpness test
to find out how sharp your weapons are i
will cut through these rolled up tatami
mats now unlike the strength test this
is all about what the edge of your
weapon will do to these mats
dusty up first you ready for this rock
and roll all right let's do that
right justin's talking about the cuts
here clearly on the other cuts they cut
all the way through on the last cut
almost but just a little skin of that
mat is hanging on but it is a sharp edge
overall sir
it will cut thank you
all right doug your turn so you ready
see what this thing can do let's do it
all right doug first cut just went so
easy without a drag that it went into
the next target
it is a very sharp weapon it's very easy
to wield and it's light
overall sir
it will cut
thank you
all right gentlemen i know i speak for
the judges when i say this is exactly
wanna see but as we know only one of you
is going to be leaving here the fortune
fire champion for the check for ten
thousand dollars
and today's fortune fire champion is
doug congratulations you won justin
unfortunately you're not going to be
leaving with the win today and doug's
going to tell you why justin on any
other given competition i can see your
blade being a champion's bait it is a
beautiful blade but today your opponents
was just a little sharper a little
lighter and faster to wield
just again thank you very much for your
hard work but unfortunately i have to
ask you to please leave the forge good
job
well doug you are the fortune fire
champion congratulations man thanks a
lot yeah what are you gonna get with
that ten thousand dollars oh i fell in
love with the forge press
i i definitely want one of those of my
own i am ecstatic you know i put a lot
of heart and soul into making that blade
and seeing it perform the way that it
did was uh just a really great
confirmation about my abilities and it's
just making me want to make more knives
you